I wrote a lot of books without knowing
my why and it convinced me that I didn't
like writing anymore because
I had such bad experiences with it
how often does a professional writer
write I believe that a professional
writer writes every day
I believe that it is one of those
skills it's sort of like the Malcolm
Gladwell 10 000 hour theory that you're
not gonna excel at something and be able
to call yourself that unless you do it
all day every day and have for a decade
or so it kind of kills me I I meet
people all the time who say
everyone tells me I'm a great writer and
I say great do you write every day well
no I mean it's people don't really get
that it's like you know it's like going
into a gym and lifting weights one day
and saying everybody tells me I'm so
good at lifting weights well if you
don't do it every day how good are you
gonna be
what if someone's a Content writer for
their job let's say
and so they think that because I'm great
at writing copy or writing stuff for you
know a brand that then I can write my
own story it should be no problem I do I
do think that if you have experience as
a copywriter as a Content writer as long
as you're putting words together every
day you're going to be in much better
shape than someone who isn't any kind of
a writer but it is a totally different
skill set I think you know it's about
it's about words and language and
psychology I find actually uh
copywriters are very interesting to me
because the work is about I became a
writer because I'm fascinated with words
in Psychology copywriters are all about
what's gonna get someone to press by
what's going to get someone to have a
response so I actually think that's
better training than a lot of other
writing
and when you set out to be a writer
quote unquote you gave yourself what you
said three pages a day did that change
did you add on more to your plate no I
was always pretty committed to the three
three pages after rewriting the three
pages from the day before because that's
the thing that can take hours and hours
and hours I'm one of these writers who I
may over edit it's very easy to get very
caught up in like let me just make this
perfect let me just make this perfect
and it's sort of like perfect as the
enemy have done and you know
perfectionism is actually just fear
wearing a disguise it's never gonna be
perfect and when I meet people who say
I'm working on my book for seven years
I'm like oh God you might be better off
starting again
well what was her name Susan she wrote
uh quiet the power of introverts she did
Susan Kane yeah she did seven years but
she admits that she enjoyed the process
so much because she's an introvert and
it was right it was all part of who she
was so right right
right
okay what should a writer know before
writing their book
a writer needs to know why they're
writing the book
um I wrote a lot of books without
knowing my why and it convinced me that
I didn't like writing anymore because
I had such bad experiences with it my
second book what happened is I had
written a story for details magazine
about high-class hookers in LA and I had
been given this assignment the editor
said go do what I'm giving you months go
infiltrate this whole CD underworld I
said great I went and did it and I
uncovered great crazy crazy things and I
had like
um I mean I had disk drives of things
that people been in prison I mean I had
lists of famous people I had the
craziest things and then my editor was
fired and another editor came in and he
said to me literally uh we just need
this to be a story about like how rich
men get off and so I was so bitter that
they had taken this amazing material I
had and made it into such a boring story
that
um my agent said to me was it was
actually when we were walking in to make
the deal for party girl she said they
may offer you a two-book deal do you
have another idea and so I just busted
out with how about a novel about
high-class hookers in Hollywood and they
said yeah that sounds good that's how I
got my second book deal
and I thought well sex cells it's a sexy
topic people are gonna like it I the
problem is I'm not interested in the
subject of hookers I don't have a
judgment about it I'm just totally bored
by it so I'm writing this book that I'm
bored by thinking oh sex cells I never
bothered to ask myself why do you want
to do if I'd asked it would have been
like well I want to do it because I'm
resentful at my editor details well
that's a stupid reason to do a book so
every author needs to say what is your
why why you why this book and why now
and if you can answer those questions
and you know what you want your reader
to do as soon as they finish writing it
then you should write your book
and of all of your books which was the
strongest why for you party girl party
girl was okay yeah it was it was
absolutely yeah
because you felt so connected to the
material because it was it was basically
you but you were sort of embellishing or
tying the other stories right yeah I
mean yeah party girl was very much my
story but it had it had a real it had a
real intention behind it and I wrote it
before I knew about Publishers and book
deals and Goodreads reviewers and nasty
comments and Book Sales and all the
things that were going to
um sort of
sadly poison the experience I it was
just written from such a pure heart what
is the process of writing a book begin
for you
the process of writing a book for me
today begins with
saying what am I interested in that
people actually want to know about and
not kind of having this vague idea but
really going out and trying out material
right now I'm writing a book that's
based on my podcast interviews and I put
out there on Twitter on LinkedIn on
Instagram I'm constantly kind of taking
the material I'm writing about and
seeing how people respond to it so
you're getting actual test cases you're
getting a b testing while you're working
on something so I need to I wrote many
books without ever bothering to ask if
anybody wanted to read them so now I get
really clear about is this a book people
are going to be interested in and then I
start writing from there
so you said with your second book you
weren't really that invested in the
topic yeah it was more because your
article was sort of kiboshed and you
thought you know what I no no I want to
take this were you surprised at the
feedback that you received that people
actually did want to know about this
like The Client List or whatever
girlfriend experience
I don't
um no I I nobody really cared about my
second book least of all me I turned
that book in and I hated it and then a
month later I said can I have it back I
want to reread it from page one and my
editor said I don't think you need to I
think it's pretty good and I said no no
no I want to rewrite it and I rewrote it
and I rewrote it and I still hated it
and honestly when I get emails from
people who tell me they love it I have
no respect for them because I hate the
books so much
so do you think that's where there was a
disconnect that maybe because you didn't
feel so personally invested that it
translated and How It Was Written yeah
yeah party girl is I wrote this book
with this pure heart and there was so
much excitement around it and it was
going to be this thing it was going to
be my dream come true and then it didn't
happen and so I forgot about the pure
heart I thought well okay I gotta be
more strategic what will sell what do
people care about and I used to make a
really big mistake in my career which is
if somebody asked me
um to like to talk about something I
took that as a sign that I should you
know I became like a sex dating and
relationship expert despite having no
interest in it because somebody offered
me the opportunity to do it so my third
book was about reality shows because at
that point I was being asked to go on TV
and talk about reality shows I didn't
have a strong affinity for reality shows
I didn't really care but it was like I
was taking what was showing up as ideas
about what I should do and I really if I
have any regrets it's that I didn't just
stop back and go hey do you care about
reality shows nope okay next pack
another opportunity will come along
which is your favorite part of the
writing process that's such a good
question I used to love uh the very end
not because you were reaching the end
but because I'm not an outliner and so I
always feel felt like the end would it
was almost a spiritual experience where
it would make sense I would write myself
to a place where I'm like oh my God if
this hadn't happened here this could
never have like it was almost like
divinely inspired not to sound totally
pompous and self-important
um at this point
um
I do like all of it I will tell you the
part I like the least is actually where
I am with the book I'm writing right now
which is after I've Rewritten it and
printed it and gone through and made
edits and you're just like oh my God I'm
on page 200 Crossing things out to make
changes and you're so sick of the
material that's when it gets hard I have
found a trick which is
um when I'm so sick of reading my own
material it's almost like an acting
exercise pretend I'm somebody else how
would I feel if I was Karen reading this
you know and I almost try to embody
somebody else so that I can actually get
fresh eyes